Recall from our last few units that lexical analysis
is the process of breaking up a string into a list of tokens.
We are now getting into syntactical analysis,
which takes a list of words and tells you if that list of words
is a valid derivation in the grammar, follows the rules
of the formal grammar, is in the language of the grammar.
All 3 of those mean the same thing.
Just as the process of doing lexical analysis is sometimes called lexing,
the process of doing syntactical analysis is called parsing.
Parsing or syntactical analysis involves breaking down a list of tokens
to see if it's valid in the grammar, or breaking down a list of words
to see if they follow the rules of a language.
To make our web browser our interpreter for HTML and JavaScript,
we're going to combine the lexing we've already learned about
with the parsing that we'll be learning in this unit and the next,
and that's going to give us a huge amount of power.
Or to put this another way, lexing word rules plus sentence rules from parsing
is going to give us a scope and a structure in which to
express creative utterances.
It's time to put those 2 great tastes together.
Here on the left I have a simple expression grammar
that mentions numbers as a terminal,
and over here on the right I have a rule
in our lexer for figuring out when a string is a number,
if it matches this particular regular expression.
If I put the 2 of these together plus a similar rule for
what it means to write a plus sign and what it means to write a minus sign,
then I can suddenly tell that more realistic strings
like 1 + 2 are valid in our language.
1 matches our rule for number.
The plus matches our rule for plus.
2 matches our rule for number, and then this whole utterance,
number plus number, is in the language of our grammar for expressions, so this is good.
Similarly, 33 is a number. 44 is a number.
Minus is the minus sign. This is great.
And over here I've got 7 + 2 - 2,
or if you like, 7 + or - 2, which I hear is a magic number.
Down here at the bottom I have a slightly longer derivation
that shows off both the grammar part
and also the lexical analysis part.
Grammar turns expression into expression plus expression.
Lexical analysis turns number into 5 or 6 or some such.